welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder is now
the closest marvel studios in disney
have gotten to a major film release day
with zero trailer as of march 29th we
are now only 101 days away from thor 4's
scheduled release of july 8th which is
coming up on universal's record of only
93 days before the incredible hulk
released in 2008 to drop that first
trailer and waiting way longer than
disney normally does for sheng chi it
was 137 days out eternals it was a whole
162 days out and waiting even longer
than sony did to drop a trailer for
spider-man no way home which we thought
was incredibly close that was 116 days
folks normally disney drops these things
like five months before the movie
releases here it's only like three
months hundred one days away so what the
hell is marvel studios hiding for thor
love and thunder now sure there are
rumors that effects work might still
need more time or that more reshoots may
be necessary especially with that rascal
taekwo dt admitting he lies to marvel
studios during development to just get
the gig and then does his own thing when
he gets to set and with thor love and
thunda shooting down undead in a
different time zone and hemisphere with
opposite seasons from burbank california
there may be some creative differences
that need to be ironed out before the
film gets marketed to the masses and
hopefully no further delays of the
release date however we got to point out
major reshoots didn't stop marvel from
dropping its first teaser for taiwan
tt's thor ragnarok a full
207 days before its release in november
2017 that trailer showed mjolnir's
destruction in an alley a sequence that
was completely reconceived rewritten and
re-shot for the final cut folks with any
marvel title there are secrets that they
want to keep under wraps and a specific
timeline in which they want to reveal
plot elements to us during the trailers
throughout the marketing process for
example you could imagine a version of
the marketing for thor ragnarok that
completely omitted the fact that hulk
was going to be in the movie they could
have just presented to us a story about
thor and loki fighting hella who breaks
mjolnir and seeks a vengeance on asgard
and thor ends up as a gladiator in jeff
goldblum's arena fighting who knows
groot drax beta ray bill and then wait
till the movie releases to reveal boom
surprise cameo hulk but now marvel
decided 207 days out to reveal thor's
green friend from work because they knew
that six months of excitement for thor
and hulk's matchup would be part of this
narrative experience so the fact that we
still got nada for thor love and thunder
suggests that this movie's plot might be
interwoven with story implications from
other marvel titles that marvel does not
want to ruin of course i'm talking
specifically about doctor strange to the
multiverse of madness a movie that was
going to come out on march 25th but back
in october it was delayed six weeks to
may 6th while thor 4 was delayed from
may 6 to july 8th nine weeks making
these movies come out three weeks closer
together than they were before and that
three-week difference actually perfectly
fits with our expectations of when we'd
be seen a thor 11 thunder first trailer
like if multiverse of madness had kept
its march 25th release marvel could have
dropped a love and thunder trailer that
week and then wouldn't have waited as
long as sony did for its trailer for no
way home none of us would be complaining
so if this whole synchronization
insanity between multiverse madness and
thor 11 thunder is legit i see three
possible secrets about the stories of
these movies that marvel might want to
keep hidden by delaying thor love and
thunder's marketing but hey imagine this
scenario you got a big date or an
important job interview or you're about
to be in front of millions of people
watching you on youtube but wait a
second what's that a huge zit who
invited that to the party well today's
sponsor frontman is here to help you
disinvite your unwelcome acne guest so
frontman fade is a skin colored cream
with proven acne fighting ingredients it
covers acne while treating it it's
dermatologists developed and made with
natural extracts
[Music]
what greasy spot look you'll be looking
better in literally 10 seconds front man
fade won't clog your pores and it's
sweat proof which is good for me because
some of my videos can get pretty intense
it's like i'm running a 10k through
these missible details and am i right so
grab yourself some frontman fade to
cover your acne while treating it head
to
befriendman.com new rockstars who use
the link in the description for 15 off
your order so here's what we know about
love and thunder so far we last saw thor
teaming up with the guardians of the
galaxy at the end of avengers end game
leaving valkyrie in charge of asgard
spider-man no way home teased that there
was political turmoil going down new
asgard suggesting there may be a threat
to valkyrie's rule or perhaps she
abdicated leaving a kind of power vacuum
now we know from set photos and merch
releases that new asgard is being turned
into a tourist attraction where visitors
can ride floating viking ships carted by
thor's two goats and that broken pieces
of mjolnir are kept on display and they
have a theater stage where they reenact
hella's destruction of mjolnir we know
that the story will adapt jason aaron's
the mighty thor comics where jane foster
wields mjolnir powering up into a female
thor to help stave off her cancer we
also know that valgarria will go by king
valkyrie and that the villain christian
bale as gore the god butcher will have
his pale sickly appearance we also know
the guardians of the galaxy will appear
in this movie and that there are rumors
that russell crowe might appear as zeus
though that has not been confirmed based
on all of this the first possible secret
i'm thinking about is that thor love and
thunder could begin with a brutal
widespread massacre of most of the gods
in the marvel cinematic universe
including our man zeus leading to the
asgardians and peter quill since he is
the son of a celestial gore the god
butcher's mission is to kill all gods
for praying to the gods did nothing to
save his family from being killed
eternals established that many planets
are being used as celestial eggs
including the mentions of past ones like
centuries six is this the century six
tina was talking about yeah it's a
planet
she thinks she used to live there until
it was destroyed
always talks about massive quakes
ripping it apart
everyone died including herself gore
could have been one of those victims his
family could have died on century six
and now the guy might continue a killing
spree to the gods and deities and
multiverse of madness as elder gods like
cathodon and his avatar wanda maximov
come into gore's crosshairs by the way
moon knight is also dealing with the
concepts of gods and avatars branching
into the world of egyptian mythology
with moon dd kanchu and devourer of the
dead emmett so exploring this whole
mythological side of the mcu seems like
it's in the cards now the second
possible secret is that thor love and
thunder might just feature a major
marvel mutant in the cast and marvel
wants to wait until after multiverse of
madness before talking about the mutants
multiverse of madness is confirmed to
feature patrick stewart as fox x-men
charles xavier telling us this is gonna
be the movie that finally populates the
mcu with mutants and there have been
some rumors that mutants like storm
could appear in thor love and thunder
also unconfirmed but perhaps that
political turmoil in new asgard could be
some drama or scandal involving valkyrie
and aurora monroe who is a mutant with
power over lightning rivaling the god of
thunder now the third possible secret
that connects these two films could
simply just be that as the first mcu
title to come out directly following a
major crossover event of multiverse
madness thor love and thunder might take
place in a post house of m reality in
which the entire landscape of the mcu
looks different and thor valkyrie loki
and the guardians could all now be in
the universe less directly set by the
events of thor ragnarok and avengers
infinity war and end game instead more
of a what if reality set in a world
after wanda reboots the entire mcu and
to show us anything from the post house
of m reality could spoil a lot of what
wanda plans to do in multiverse of
madness now obviously some continuity is
gonna have to be maintained in thor love
and thunder like new asgard is still
located in norway hella still had
destroyed mjolnir but perhaps multiverse
madness will end with certain variants
respawning in the mcu who had died
before like loki heimdall the warriors
three odin hella all these people
returning could be that political
turmoil of new asgard described in the
no way home ticker just no matter what
folks i think marvel is gonna really
need us to see multiverse madness before
thor love and thunder because i swear to
god that next person to post a stupid
semi-truck trailer meme i'm gonna tell
will you said something about jada
follow me on instagram and twitter at ea
boss follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you